when did you first start hearing the
stories about your father and how long
of a process was this - getting to this
moment look how old I look that's how
long
well I should say I lived it I was
actually I'm the older of the two
brothers but I was actually five when it
happened we just cast the kids a little
older so we didn't have little babies on
the set so I lived that and I was very
aware of that because my dad was leaving
and my mother was upset and then my
father right after Christmas brought me
up to dr. Chile's loft above Carnegie
Hall and it was like Dorothy walking
into Oz it was quite an amazing place
and you know the chandeliers the grand
piano and the throne the throne was
right there and he sat me on the throne
my father said hey doc play him a little
something when he played for me so I
never forgot it so when I got older you
know started hearing the stories asking
about the stories I'm wearing a little
little over than that and I thought I
wanted to do this as a film so tape
recording my father telling me all the
stories and then he said all right we
got to talk to dr. Shelly so I spoke to
him as well and I put it all together
and dr. Shelly said I don't want you to
make this film I weigh just put in
everything that I've told you and your
father has told you but I want you to
wait till I'm gone whenever that may be
so I respected his wishes so it took a
while thank God he lived a long long
healthy life but a couple years ago to
15 I decided to really do it and I
thought you know my whole life I was
overdoing myself I said well maybe I
shouldn't just do it myself maybe we
should bring in another writer and for
another so it's not just me you know in
my vision so I brought on a friend Bryan
curry who brought it to Pete and then
Pete wanted to meet me and you know I
was kind of stubborn about it I said I
was something I got to do but second I
met Pete we discussed it I knew like my
dad was kicking me in the head saying
let Pete run with this I like we did
what kind of spoke to you about this
particular story because it is a bit of
a departure from the comedies you've
made yeah you know it wasn't trying to
do
departure which I should have been
trying to do by the way
III always say that I look at like Rob
Reiner career and he started with spinal
tap than he did a sure thing then he did
you know stand by me and then a few good
men and within four movies he kind of
showed he could do everything and we
didn't and part of it was that we you
know we write our own material and we
were you know in the comedy thing we
kind of got stuck there but it when I
heard this story the thing that got me
was Bryan Hayes Curry told me the story
he says you know black concert pianist
1962 Don Shurley
he needed a he was going through the
south he was nervous about going so he
hired the toughest bouncer in New York
City a guy Italian guy named Tony lips
sixth grade education but really didn't
pay attention after third grade and and
he and and Tony lip was racist himself
and yet somehow at the end of this
journey they became lifelong friends
that's what got me yeah I think if they
had just gone on this trip and been
ended as enemies I don't think I would
have done it I just didn't see the point
but I was so interested like how they
overcame this huge you know valley this
hurdle and that's what drew me in vigo
I'm just curious to know when you agreed
to sign on what's like the first step is
it finding a donut store or is it or is
it fine is it asking for the audio
footage like what had to come first for
you to become Tony pizza actually the
first thing when I hung it took a little
doing I mean I'm Pete's part I was very
cowardly about it really and when he
first he said I'm sending you this story
it's a departure for me please read it
if you don't like it that's fine you
know but please read this and if then if
you want to talk about it here's my
number or whatever right and so I read
this script starts out great it gets
better it gets better among once this
gonna fall apart and yes it is a
departure and
and there's so much and I finish the
script I thought wow this is not only
one of the best screenplays original
screenplay sev read this year but in a
long long time
I just thought how I mean just it the
writing made the writing look easy if
that makes sense
in other words there's so much going you
know it's funny it's very moving it's
based on real people there's a history
lesson a civics lesson it's profound it
gets better it goes up and it goes out
and there's layers and layers and
sparkling dialogue and the characters
are well drawn it's just like I finish I
have one that's amazing and the only
thing is I'm reading he's an Italian
American guy he's a real person that
existed in my life yeah well so I called
Pete and I said it's I can't I can't
even find the words to say how much I
like the script but I think you're
already taking a swerve and doing
something new doing a drama and why
don't you cast an italian-american actor
there's a lot of good ones out there I
mean now you really asked him for
trouble you know and and he was like no
no no I'm he had no doubts in his mind
but I had a lot of doubts in my mind I
said well let me can I sleep on it I
just let me read it one more time I
promise to call tomorrow so I bit the
bullet and said okay I I'm gonna have
faith in you and not be such a you know
coward really and do it but then then I
hung up the phone and then I went to the
bathroom I look at myself in mirrors
you're an idiot now you have to do this
you know but that's a common thing for
actors I think but in someone is more it
feels like more of a stretch but I
immediately relied on Nick Vallelunga
who was helpful to Linda and to me I
mean immensely opened up his arms who's
opened the door to his house and to his
family and his uncles and unbeknownst to
Pete many of them were being cast maybe
you can tell the story there's a lot of
non actors in that family I mean what
Pete said to me one of the things that
demean casting me said I don't want to
have faces that you recognize from other
American family movies or stories I want
to do something different in principle
it's a great idea but it's very risky
unless you really know what you're gonna
do once you have a good game plan and
you're as calm as he is under fire it's
risky you know but it worked great I
mean it's it's unbelievable anyway
without the veil along a family there's
no way I could have gotten done what I
did just didn't preparing the character
you know and my intention always like
any actor I think is you don't want to
do a caricature of anybody what were you
most excited to kind of bring out in
this character there was so much that
was exciting about it for me the idea
that there was a true story the script
was fantastic like you know like Vigo
said and and aside from all of that and
the meaning that it seemed to hold Vigo
and my Herschel oh I knew they were
already cast I knew Pete's work and I
thought there's a sense of humor in here
and if you're not funny that can be
totally missed and I think that's a
great strength that Pete has that that
other directors you you you can't just
discover that about yourself either has
sense of humor or you don't and you can
and I think you know he can do it broad
but he can also do it small and I think
that's what truly funny people can bring
out is the humanity in each character
and they become more than just something
on a page right and I think you know
Vigo is hilarious the humor was was such
a wonderful and surprising and beautiful
thing that that actually lends itself to
creating more of a powerful story I
think so that was exciting to me but you
know just I auditioned for this role and
I got called up and I was working on
something else and I was working you
know terrible hours you know you work
long long hours and I had done a 12 or
14 hour day I had no clothes with me for
an audition but I thought well I'm just
gonna go I borrowed clothes from
wardrobe but it was a 70s period piece
so I had like bell-bottoms and a shirt I
try to tuck it I try to do something and
and I showed up and they just want to
hear you read it and when I got there
Vigo was sitting at a table with props
and I thought oh god I I just looked at
this a few times just kind of like
warm-up or something and before I knew
it we were sitting there
acting at the table was I was serving
him spaghetti we were pretending to eat
it we were you know we were doing all of
these things and I stayed in there you
guys waited for me late at night I
stayed in there for a long time and then
as I left I thought you know what I feel
like I feel like I could have done more
I feel like there's someone I got a
phone call come back in on a Saturday
morning so I come in on a Saturday
morning and we go and we were sitting
there just kind of going over things we
start improving we start starting just
doing the things because I come from a
big family so some of that stuff seems
so natural to me and and then after that
audition I was thinking oh god what just
happened in there like did I just think
we're great and the first time you did
it and the first day Pete was just
playing with your mind how does it
change the game as a composer when your
subject of the film is a musician yeah I
think first of all I had never heard of
dr. shirlee before this film and it was
such an incredible gift to not only
discover the music but then I have to
start to investigate it and learn it and
all of that and basically when we were
looking at trying to do the going to the
score Pete and I talked about trying to
differentiate the sound between dr.
Shirley's music that we had pre-recorded
to sound like his trio with piano bass
and cello and the sound of the scores we
decide to go with an orchestra for the
sound but in order to figure out like
you said some sort of continuity between
it all I just started looking at all of
dr. Shirley's actual influences the he
was really influenced obviously by just
the entire classical and jazz canon but
in addition to that a lot of Negro
spirituals a lot of early gospel music
and he all he used it in a way that I
had never heard before when I first
heard his music so then I started to
look at again dr. Shirley's music and
look at a bunch of folk melodies and
Negro spiritual melodies and gospel
music and I started to write all of my
themes for the score at the piano as if
they were going to be just like a gospel
song or a folk melody or a Negro
spiritual and basically just play it
over and over again and keep tinkering
with it until I could play it and feel
like it sounded like that and then I
wouldn't orchestrated at all to have
bit more of the influence of reveller
Debussy or Gershwin the other influences
of dr. Shirley and so that's kind of
what we did to try to again have some
sort of cohesion between the two things
but still have them sound completely
different Marshall I'm a piano player so
I always pay very close attention to
actors playing in the piano you are
exceptional at let the finger work and
everything it is so realistic I know
your character on Luke Cage also plays
piano so maybe you've worked on there's
a big difference in how Luke cage the
cage plays piano on this character right
I had Chris and I worked for for a few
months coming into this and Chris does
Chris does the fingering it's a it's a
composite but but out the main thing in
coming into it that I wanted to do with
Chris and when I first when Pete first
approached me about working on this film
that was just like Vigo talks about I
don't know if he shared this with you
today about his concern about playing in
Italian Italian American yeah well I
whined about it for quite a while
I'm not a musician I'm an actor I got to
act like I'm a musician you know and but
I trained to to pretend well you know
and and Chris to help me Chris helped me
quite a bit with that and so the focus
for me was one I don't want to be a
distraction to the audience and do a
disservice to dr. Shirley your musicians
in general and two I need to know where
I'm at in the story
I'm not playing where I'm at is not the
same place each time I'm sitting down at
that piano so as an actor it's not about
just plug in the next musical song like
where am I at I came from a place as I
rushed on I got a story coming coming
into this space right so we've done 20 q
and A's you're in a different space
every time you walk in a QA right from
what you brought in this space as you
come to sit down in this chair so every
time you sit down at that piano where
are we in the story you know and so
that's what that was that's where my
focus was you know and
all the other stuff everything we did to
make sure that that's believable and me
practicing the piano and practicing with
Chris and making sure the hands and arms
in the right place that stuff is kind of
technical you know but it's more about
what was going on in the interior for me
so you know what you guys made beautiful
music together and I'm just so glad you
all were able to be here to tell us
about it